yeah well i mean it's absolutely the
heart of this and i would say in two
senses first of all specifically as i
was saying earlier in relation to
jerusalem
um because unless you have some concept
of parity
in a city that is open for worship by
not just obviously jews and muslims but
by christians too
i mean it's very hard
to see how you can you i mean there will
be no resolution of this dispute without
a resolution of the issue of jerusalem
because it is for
um
muslims a holy place for jews of course
and and
you know also for christians um but
so in respect of jerusalem
unless you have some concept of equality
or parity of religious
um
esteem then then it's very hard to to
make it work but the other thing is very
specifically actually and partly
you know one of the bizarre things about
this situation is
that
that
if you look at
this poorly drawn map
um
actually israel is obviously the
dominant party
right with the dominant share of
resources
and the dominant
amount of amount of money
if you look at this poorly drawn map
it's actually not obviously
okay
and therefore one thing that's
really very important in this and we
where where i think that this concept of
reconciliation based on an understanding
that there is a proper theological
justification for such reconciliation
is precisely because otherwise
there is a danger that israelis believe
well these people can just be basically
relegated
and there is a danger that these people
basically believe the only answer to
these people is to squash them
so you know i think
you know
you know and one of the ways this
happens in steny very oddly is that
you know the palestinian authority
requires
to get it's about
60 of its budget now but it's coming
down in fact because of the in fact the
palestinians doing quite a good
job now under the prime minister fired
at governing six cent the budget comes
from foreign aid
but guess who the two biggest funders of
the palestinians
you'd think it would be from here
but actually it's europe and america are
the two biggest funders
right
now
in fact
if and i often say this to the arab
countries if you take a country like
saudi it's got the resource
to make a huge difference to the
palestinian gdp but actually it's very
hard to get
at the moment the saudis to fund
the palestinian authority because they
believe that in funding it they're in a
sense accepting
the status quo which is
you know which which they argue is is
unjust
but if you actually look at how you
resolve this thing overall
it can only ever be resolved on the
basis
that this
you know
arab world of
several hundred million except that this
state of whatever it is seven i guess
has a right to exist
and this state seven accepts that
these
are going to be treated equally and and
without
a basis of doing that that's about
values and not just self-interest or
territorial negotiation
you've got a problem
and that's why you know it it
because
then what some people here think is look
we can just basically carry on sitting
on them and we'll have the support of
various allies and so on and in you know
in in doing that and then these people
say well look we've got no option but to
just under we accept the fact that we're
at war so
this reconciliation won't happen
unless it's grounded
in a concept of
values and not just interests and
possibly even more specific
specifically in a concept of faith
that gets you beyond
the power relationships
to a partnership and a parody of esteem
that is based
actually on something that is as much
um
spiritual
and
religious as it is political or
practical